foreign
[Music]
and welcome to today's webinar reverse
engineering the human heart with
pluripotent stem cells I'm Cassie
saltman of lab roots and I'll be your
moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by BPS bioscience to learn more
visit bpsbioscience.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation to do so simply
type them into the ask a question box
and click Send we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation you may also submit
any technical issues here as well if you
have trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation
I'd like to now welcome our speaker Ator
Aguirre assistant professor biomedical
engineering Chief division of
Developmental and Stem Cell Biology
Institute for quantitative Health
Science and Engineering co-director MSU
stem cell core facility Michigan State
University
Dr akure is a stem cell biologist
developmental biologist and bioengineer
who specializes in the heart he studies
basic aspect of human cardiac
development congenital heart disease and
cardiac regeneration Dr Aguirre has
received numerous Awards and published
in prestigious journals today he will
discuss methods to generate human heart
organites using human pluripotent stem
cells Dr Aguirre may now begin your
presentation
thank you so much for the introduction
Cassie and thank you everyone for being
here today and the organizers for the
invitation
so as Cassie said I'm gonna be talking
today about how we are trying to reverse
engineer the human heart with third
party stem cells
um
so let me get started
so uh the human heart is a very
complicated organ it's a very powerful
pump and you know I like to compare it
to an engine uh I live in Michigan as
you know as many of you might know
Michigan used to be the the heart of the
uh of the car industry in the United
States and in the world I would say and
I like to make this comparison of the
heart to one of the engines that you
know Henry Ford was making at the start
of the 20th century and so I'm going to
use a little bit of a comparison between
a pump and an engine here and and and
I'm gonna you know I'm gonna try to make
this kind of uh analogy
um
I you know I give this talk to several
different types of uh public sometimes
it's people that are more into the
cardiovascular field sometimes these
people that are more just into stem
cells so I have a couple of areas like
that are going to be more setting up
what's the problem with cardiovascular
biology and how we can use the stem
cells to address that problem
um so that said let's move forward
so the heart as what would happen with
the normal engine also suffers from wear
and tear over the life of the over our
life right um and so here I can I have
some pictures and some images uh
representative of what happens with the
heart along Our Lives um
on the top right of the top left corner
you have the uninfected heart you can
see the infart on the wall of the heart
and to the right of it you have a heart
that has a hypertrophic cardiomyopathy
so these are parts of problems that
constitute cardiovascular disease which
is the main cause of death in the
developer ahead of cancer
and this is a health problem that is
continually increasing and that it's
very difficult to manage
and you have a break round there of the
different types of cardiovascular
disease you can see that the most common
one is by far
um the most
you know uh uh the one with the highest
mortalities by far that can be hard
disease but there's there's a fair
number of all the problems associated
with cardiovascular
um uh Health
um
another type of friends that we can find
with the heart aside from wear and tear
it's what in engineering terms we would
call defective manufacturing so it's a
hard that it's not correctly made
um and this is what happens with
congenital heart defects which is
another significant uh source of
cardiovascular disease in the developed
world uh congenital heart defects are
the most common type of birth defect of
malformation in humans
and they affect about one percent of all
life births in healthy uh doing healthy
pregnancies
and I have a couple of examples there of
congenital heart defects I'm not going
to go a lot of into detail into this
because this is usually more specific
for a kind of vascular audience but you
know they range from defects on the on
the formation of the walls that separate
the different parts of the heart and you
know the effects on the formation of the
tubing basically that that joins the
heart which is the arteries and the
veins right
so what kind of tools do we have to
address cardiovascular disease to study
cardiovascular disease and to try to uh
identify therapies and new ways to to
attack this problem so I would say most
of you if not all are very familiar with
animal models
and I put there three pictures of some
of my favorite animal models the mouse
the Pig and the zebrafish and they have
a significant advantages and this has
been I would say the main driver during
the last
Century almost I would say
um which is the fact that these models
are physiologically relevant
they are evolutionarily conservant
that's the reason they are useful to
study human cardiovascular problems is
because you know there's a fair degree
of conservation but there's some they
also have significant limitations one of
them is the species differences and
mountains of the person and their
metabolism for example is very different
and depending on the organ that you are
studying these differences might be more
more of a problem right like in the case
of the heart metabolism and how the
heart uses energy and you know specific
parts of the heart like the epicario and
it was fat those are things that are not
found in some of these animal models for
example in the muscle in the sea
Graphics so in those aspects we are
lacking systems that are more
appropriate for humans
um another one of the problems that
comes with animals is the lack of fine
control and this is just self-evident
right like if you have an animal
um you know the physiology of the whole
animal will compensate sometimes for
problems that you might find in the
heart so that kind of obscured uh access
to the phenotypes or the the features
that you want to start and this is true
of all animal models it's not really a
specific to cardiovascular vertices and
finally there is um I would say a recent
you know Rising topic which is societal
pressure against the use of animal
models particularly against the use of
some types of animal models and I think
this is a trend that is going to
continue you know pressing and it's
going to continue getting more popular
so we need to find alternatives to to
this
and I think um sorry I continue using my
arrow in the keyboard but I have to
press on the screen
um this is where human models become
useful so human models they've been
introduced for some years we started
using cancer transform cell lines but in
recent years we have started to use more
uh you know relevant physiologically
relevant human cell types like you know
reporting stem cells that I've thesis
and some of the advantages of these are
the the file control that we can accept
because these are vitro systems right so
we can control every little component of
the media we can we have access
continuously to the cells Etc so we can
excite verify control but the problem
that they have is the lack of
physiological relevance right and we all
know that um
I would also like to say that there's
also societal pressure to adopt more of
these models uh ongoing in in recent
years
so the talk is going to focus on our
attempts at reverse engineering the
human heart so that we can create human
hearts in vitro which is one of the
short terms uh you know
models which is one of the short terms
goals of our lab we are also interested
in the teacher engineering compatible
hard Parts compatible for
transplantation which is a longer term
role using these same approaches and
eventually in the future that I might
not get to see we would like to be able
to create human hearts in the novel
basically in vitro completely
and today's talk it's gonna be focused
on this first aim where we have made a
lot of progress in the last four years
so to be able to replace engineer a
heart the first thing that we need to do
is deconstructed we need to know what is
it made of what is the structure which
of what are the cell types right
and I think sometimes there is a
persistent thought around the people
that are not specializing in the heart
to think that the heart is relatively
simple in terms of cell types like most
people work with cardiomyocytes 99 of
the time but the heart is actually
complex in terms of cell types it
possesses cardiomycy it's only make up
for about half of the heart
uh equals this is a series of other cell
types
they are described there fibroblasts the
picardial cells and the female cells
there's others but it also has a very
sophisticated uh structure right like
it's a pump it's a very sophisticated
pump so it has chambers that are
separated by Valves and a series of
connections that are the outflow tract
and tubes and it also is subjected to
Mechanical forces and blood flow so it
is a physically complex organ and also
structurally and anatomically
so we need to recognize first this this
complexity before we can start trying to
separate these parts to reconstruct an
image
um so I like to show this diagram that
shows how a human heart is forming a
memory
as my first uh you know step to explain
how we are going to try to reconstruct
the human heart so here you have uh
starting from left to right you have the
formation of the cardiac Crescent which
is the first structure during heart
development that will give rise to the
heart and you have the different I would
say the most important steps there the
cardiac Crescent the formation of the
heart tube early looping which will give
rise to the earlier structures that
eventually will become the different
cardiac chambers septation of the heart
and then after birth the personal heart
consumers continues growing
significantly during our life which is
also something very important to take
into account
so this first structure of the cardiac
Crescent it possesses its form
essentially by two uh populations of
stem cells called the first and second
heart fields which will give rise to a
lot of the basic scaffolding we could
say that forms the early heart
um
but there's other few other stem cell
populations that come and contribute to
this structure one of them is the
propicardial organ which is a you could
consider the third heart field that
migrates on top of the structures
created by the first and second heart
field and it contributes to
proteocardial cells fibroblasts blood
vessels Etc
then there is also another population
that migrates onto the heart
uh after these three Fields have been
established which is the neural crest
which comes from the ectoderm and this
cells that will migrate through the
heart of the embryo and they will invade
and populate the heart a little bit
later in development as you can see
there are about 4.5 weeks after after
conception in humans and they will
contribute to very important structures
too such as the septum The Outfield
tract the conductance system
and finally there's also uh embryonic
monocyte circulating in the body of the
embryo that will travel to the heart and
will get integrated into the heart and
become diesel resident macrophages and
it's been shown in Miles models that
this Brazilian macrophages are very
important for the maturation of the
heart and basically the sculpting that
in writing heart
uh moderating its blood vessels
stylizing them creating parts of the
conductance system
Etc
so I would say these are the four the
five main cell types so five main
heart fields that will contribute to
making a heart but then we also have
factors that are exogenous to the heart
itself we have factors Like Oxygen
availability
growth factors produced by neighboring
tissues are organs during development
also we have the maternal environment
growth factors that are provided by
mother and nutrients that are provided
by the mother through the placenta and
obviously we have workload that's the
embryo grows and becomes more and more
independent from the mother the
the Warlock increases significantly and
the Heart response uh
um a very quick note
um on self-organization
in the stem cells I want to mention this
because a lot of what I'm going to be
presenting far down the road is going to
be based on self-organization so I want
to make sure that this concept is
understood by everyone so
self-organization is a property of stem
cells which means that they have they
exist in a state where they can
interpret certain sequels
um developmental signals in a way that
allows them to create higher organ
higher organization structures
and this is done through the use of
morphogene gradients during development
as stable switches and so that
mechanisms I just want to
highlight this aspect I'm not going to
delve too much into it because we could
do a whole talk about uh different
self-organization uh mechanisms and
signaling Pathways but my point is that
you know
um you start with a you know single cell
fertilized oxide and you get a whole
human being so you can I think that's
prove more than sufficient of how
powerful self-organization stem cells
it's
foreign
and so most of the work that we are
doing
um it's at the work that I'm going to be
presenting here today it's based on the
use of repository stem cells
um why do we use three Republican stem
cells because they can make all the
organs and tissues in the body of the
embryo right and so this is the perfect
setting for recreating organizing vitro
if you know the uh you know induction
steps that will give rise to to that
organ
stencils can be obtained from two
sources they can be embryonic um it
which was described by James Thompson in
1998 or they can be
induced by Republic stem cells that were
described by takahazin jamalaka in 2007.
um we use both types we normally use I
use food product stem cells for most
things because they are easier to
justify that but we use both and the
work that you are going to see here
today has been performed on both
different cell types
and so prepotence themselves as I said
before we use them because uh you know
they allow us to create unlimited
amounts of human tissues in vitro and so
they are the perfect setting for
creating human organoids
uh I'm gonna move forward from these and
why are we using organoids uh well I
think Organics are
um an evolution of the traditional
tissue culture and 3D cultural
approaches that we have been seeing
um you know over the last couple of
decades and my definition of an organoid
and this might be fair from the
definition of organic that other people
use but this is the functional
definition that I like to use it makes
this emphasis on on function and
structure
um for me to consider something an
organoid I like to say it needs to be a
complex mixture of cells that
recapitulate the structure the structure
and function of the organ they imitate
to a significant extent and I like to
use this definition to stay clear of
things like spheroids or you know
cultures or different cell types in
three dimensions because sometimes those
things are not representative of an
organ or they are only
um you know
I would say tangentially representative
of an organ so that is the definition of
organic that are going to be using
through through this talk
um and I mean there's I think everyone
at this point is familiar with the
advantages of using organized approaches
I like to use this slide from a nature
reviews paper
um but I like to highlight well these
are some of the advantages right but I
like to highlight one of the drawbacks
of organized which is their lack of
physiological complexity or or you know
physiological relevance like they do
have a lot of physiological relevance
but the brand that we have and why they
cannot substitute animal models because
they still lack a lot of physiological
relevance compared to an animal model
um and I think that's a point that we
can make a lot of progress we can
improve on um
and so there's been significant recent
advances on the creation of human heart
organized in recent years
um and I'm sure many of you will be
familiar with some of these papers
our work on these started on 2020 with
this by archive publication I think what
is interesting about all of these
you know recent Publications it's the
fact that all of them make a strong
emphasis on self-organization which is
what I'm going to be talking about it
really stopped
um so with that introduction done let's
start talking a little bit more about
the interesting meat bits which is the
results
so um
as I said we are trying to apply a
modular engineering approach to building
a heart in vitro so the first thing that
we have to do if we want to make a heart
it's we have to put the basic
scaffolding as I said before the first
and second heart fields and we can do
that
excuse me we can do that using um the
cardiac disorder induction in vitro this
has been described before for you know a
number of years for monolayer and
steroids
um these two hard Fields will give rise
to the ventricle and the Atria and parts
of the outflow tract and they can be
induced by temporal wind signaling
modulation so basically if we activate
the wind signaling pathway we will
understand the conditions of reporting
stem cells we will get these heart
Fields
you know arising sometimes and I'm going
to highlight that this work was done by
one of my first graduate students
Jonathan Lewis's Riley which was a DNA
graduate student and he already
graduated
so what Johnny did is he used uh
reporting stem cells he spin them in a
96 well played and so he could get a
embryant bodies basically that we then
triggered with the wind activation and
inhibition typical steps described
before
um
to start setting up our protocol I would
like to say also before I move forward
that the we had a couple of
um
guidelines on how we wanted our hard
differentiation organized protocol to
work and they were we needed to have
scalability that's the reason we use 96
for the plates we wanted to have high
efficiency in there in Canada in cardiac
differentiation and we wanted to have
very high reproducibility so these were
our three goals when we started this
protocol
um because we want this to be useful
fired on the road for pharmacological
testing among other things
um so we tested several different cell
lines we could get very reproducible
results across and radical stem cells
and ipcs and you can see here what the
organs look like very spherical
fundamentally cardiac cardiomyocyte like
tissues
and so once we were sure that this part
of the protocol was working well we
introduced
our next step it was the addition of a
probicarial organ to this to this uh to
this setting so the prepicarium gives
rise to the epicardium it enables
vascularization
contributes to the formation of Barbara
Artisans and some missing kind of
tissues in the heart
foreign
population of wind signaling in this
case it's a it's a third step in the
protocol shown before where we activate
wind signal in a day seven again
but different from uh the previous steps
shown this step has to be very well
timed it's a very short exposure
and it only affects the outer layers of
the heart so that way we induce a
brachycardial organ without the need to
add exogenous cells on the pre-existing
article and this is what we need here
and you can see here the the
experimental
schematic and here you can see the
prepricarian organ forming and how it
spreads out around the organoid as a
green layer and they need penetrates
inside of the organic and he tries to
other pieces
um I put two pictures here to show you
what the these organs look at day 15. so
here you can see the organs in the 96
World planes they are these tiny little
spheres they are about 1 to 1.5
millimeters in diameter here you can see
a close-up
and uh we decided to do a Time course
transcriptomic analysis so that we could
determine if you know the right cell
types uh kind of in Mass where we're
being expressed correctly uh the right
you know um
genotology processes related to cardiac
differentiation and maturation etc etc
and that's basically what we saw and you
know we then we look more in detail into
different types of genes that were
expressed from the Sacred Heart the
first heart field signal heart field and
some of the stuff that we found was that
the complexity of the organizing to be
higher than we initially expected so
there were more cell types there than
cell types that we haven't used and we
suspected this was because of
self-organization inside of the organ
um and so basically we saw markers for
the conduction system we saw markers for
endocardium with some markers for
arterial and then using the feeling for
example and we also saw that these
organoids in terms of complexity they
look closer to Federal gestational uh
effects from humans than uh you know
monolayer differentiation cells which I
would say is something that we would be
expecting
so we started to look uh to do some
structural analysis to see what were the
structures that were found in in this
order so what we found out is that the
organisms would develop a first and
second heart field that would actually
segregate I would separate and would
form sequentially in the organoids
and we also found that
we would get I3 ventricular
specification and again we would see
these atrial ventricular cells
segregating and forming and more
ventricular and more atrial
um you know structures
um
we also found that the the cell types
found in the organoids uh there were
some cell types present but we didn't
use that were formulas spontaneously uh
like cardiac fibroblasts as you can see
here and we also saw the position with
Rich cardiac fetal extra cellular matrix
I'm not showing the data here because we
probably will have time but
um
that was also very interesting finding
and we also see that the Organics form
nice endothelial cell uh structures
inside of them and this endothelial cell
cells are embedded into the myocardial
vessel you can see here the endothelial
networks and here you can see a 3D
reconstruction sorry I'm saying here
because I can see my contact you guys
probably cannot see the pointer
um
in in the top row merge you can see the
the nice and affiliate features forming
inside of an organoid and on the right
you can see a 3D reconstruction done by
confocal Imaging where you can see blood
vessels in green going through the
myocardial muscle
and we could also see that the Organics
form endocardial cells as you can see
here so we could see these structures
that we could see a structure that we're
looking kind of like a spherical inside
of the organoids you can see in the
merge on the top merch there you can see
one of those structures we were not sure
what these structures were if they were
cysts or if they were actually Chambers
um but what we could see is that they
were endocardial cells positively
labeled in endocaryations that were
lining this internal chamber so we
thought this by actually cardiac
Chambers and so we move on to basically
verify these were real Chambers so we
contacted one of our collaborators Dr
chansel at Washington University he's an
expert in Optical Aquarius tomography
which is a non-invasive and longitudinal
Imaging method
that uses a visible light
um and so it basically uses visible
light that can penetrate through the
organized but it doesn't damage it so we
can do live analysis and it can
penetrate the depth of the organoid and
so basically you can reconstruct the
whole structure and then we could
basically see very nice Chambers forming
inside of the organoid
at earlier stages which is what you saw
me here these organelles have multiple
Chambers like usually five four six
um these Chambers are extremely Dynamic
and they merge and eventually after a
couple of days at about day 20 day 25
this chamber is usually emerging to two
larger chambers that we will see later
on in more detail
um on the top on the bottom row you can
see a picture a bright field microscopy
picture one of our organoids
you can see the organic they're beating
very robustly
and you can see the chambers inside too
um so this is basically what these
organists look at about day 15 day 15
day 20. still they are pretty mature I
would say
um we have been continuing to develop
these Technologies for Life learning
basic image in the Organics which is a
field that it's experienced a lot of
growth now with Dr Cho at Washington
University and here we have basically
developed a microscope that we call the
octoscope that can uh you know high
content screen of organizer here you can
see the results this is an organized
with two Chambers and we have this valve
structure in the middle that is
separating the two Chambers and when
you're going to beat the chamber closes
um
and on the right on the right you can
see a conductance velocity map
capture at the same time using this this
methodology
um another aspect that we needed to uh
check with our organisms was the
electrophysiological relevance and this
was a little bit challenging because the
ornaments are pretty big and when they
beat they move they beat very strongly
they float and they move around but we
found a collaborator Dr Wendy here at
MSU that develops flexible electrodes
and so she basically has electrodes
where we can place the organoid and
you're gonna eat sinks inside of the
electrode and the electrode kind of
envelops the organoid and so we could do
multi-electronal wave analysis using
this methodology and you can see here
that you're going to have very nice
electrical patterns and they have
actually a physiological
you know rather similar to what you
would see in a human right saving that
you know distances but we have curious
complexes p waves T waves it looks
absolutely very nice
um so I hope that I have convinced you
that you know we had a good oriented
model heart organ and model that models
the the early heart development to a
significant extent
um and so once we reach this point we
wanted to start doing some
um disease mode to see if our Organics
can recapitulate features seen in humans
in in human disease and the system that
we chose to study was pretty stational
diabetes
um for institutional diabetes
as the the finest diabetes during the
first trimester of pregnancy and so I'm
not talking about gestational diabetes
that usually arises later now if a woman
has diabetes during the first trimester
of pregnancy which usually means that
she's either type 1 or type 2 diabetic
person that was diabetic before the
pregnancy
um the risk of the embryo to suffer
cardiovascular congenital heart defects
increases very very significantly you
can go up between 4 to 12 times
up to four to twelve percent of of of
Life variants which is a very
significant increase
um and this is a significant an increase
in medical problem so we wanted to see
if we can model this system in our own
improve their their validity proof of
concept of their use as a medical term
and so what we did is we recreated the
conditions of pre gestational diabetes
that the embryo says in the in the
uterus
um in vitro so we added glucose and
Insulin in some cases uh recapitulating
basically the same features that anemia
would see so I want to highlight that
these conditions that we use were very
mild conditions so we are using
conditions that are seen in the majority
of women so this is not the level of
glucose that is in the extreme range or
a level of insulin that's in the extreme
range these are this is inducing but in
the middle range
um because we wanted it to be as
relevant as possible physiologically
speaking for humans
and so what you can see here on the left
is normal normal glycemic hard organized
and they chose and pgdho stands for
registrational diabetes heart and
organoids and so the the first feature
that we notice is that registration all
diabetes organs they grow much faster
and larger and this is interesting
because this is morphological
differences are are
you know are following humans too like
microsonic organs are typical of kids
babies born from you know pretty
stational and stational diabetes mothers
um but we also saw that the structure of
the organisms was was affected
and um when we did ultrastructural
analysis and electrophysiology what we
saw is that at the structural level uh
the progesterone Dynamics organs
accumulated fat in their in their
cytoplasm so you can see here uh the
accumulation like when it says LD those
are lipid droplets and I stands for
mitochondria
um we saw a lot of lipid droplets
accumulated in presentation allowance
organs and we also saw
um
electrophysiological abnormalities
sometimes we saw arrhythmias
um not always but we saw significant
arrhythmias occasionally
um I'm not sure what is the clinical
significance of visual because I speak
with I've spoken with clinicians that
tell me that this is clinically
irrelevant because these children don't
see these feet are you know apparently
you know pediatric patients don't see
everything else but some of the people
have told me that it is actually
clinically relevant and they are also
clinicians so I'm at the crossroads here
but maybe farther in time we can answer
this question better
um
a very interesting aspect that we
observe is that the development of of uh
of structural and developmental defects
right which is something that
um I think it's it's it's very telling
of the other markets that this place is
in the heart so we can see for example
here you can see
um where it says normally semi-hard
organized and they chose you can see a
staining for ventricular and atrial and
myosins and you can see that both
Chambers uh segregate nicely and and
there's there's you can see Chambers
inside there but if you look at the per
institutional diabetes like heart
organoids you can see that the chambers
do not segregate they are actually
intermingle to a great extent
and the cardiac muscle there the Milson
staining looks very uncompacted the
muscle looks kind of like a spongy if
you want and we saw that this was very
repressively found across many organs
we also did the uh RNA expression for
the two conditions in the organism we
could see that many critical you know
transcription factors uh leading to the
formation of the first hard field signal
heart field where um
dysregulated in time basically so they
were expressed in very different
patterns as they were typically they
were typically expressed in a healthy
organoid
now we could also
we can also dissociate the organoids and
replay the cells in the organized for
looking at the cardiomyocytes and that's
what we did here and what we could see
is that precisional diabetes organoids
they develop hypertrophy which is it's a
very well-defined feature in in
gestational appreciation of diabetes in
children
you know newborns from precisional
diabetes matters will have a
hypertificate hypertrophy
um
that feels like here with the organoids
we could also recapitulate all the
phenotypes that have been observed in
mice such as mitochondrial stress
mitochondrial oxidative stress and you
can see that in the bottom panel
um and you can see that the mitochondria
they become like dense spots which is
basically you know bloated mitochondria
um
and we could also we also did perform
single cell RNA sequencing to identify
uh widespread developmental lineage
alterations what we're interested in
seeing how the you know glucose exposure
would actually affect the formation of
the different units in the heart
and we found very interestingly that
Precision alignments affected
cardiomyocytes and it also very
significantly affected in Metro
cardiometrics there's a population of
cardiomyosites in our organized that are
still undecided or what they are and
they they are still developing basically
so those those projector cardiometers
were very effective but I think one of
the things that most so that surprised
me the most was the effect on epicario
cells epicardial cells incredibly
expanded in uh in just precisional
diabetes like conditions and they went
from being about three percent of the
organoids to be about 25 problems and I
think this is a very relevant finding
that hasn't been found that hasn't been
observed before in nights
uh because
um the epicardium refers to epicardial
Fat which is this this protective layer
on the other side of the heart but it
also is a very strong metabolic tissue
that regulates the axis of the heart to
uh to fatty acids and so I think this
might metabolically be very important
but anyway this is a an initial
observation we also can see there how
the first heart feel and the second
heart field as identified by those three
markers and it's uh inside
um uh it's altered in this precious
station of diabetic like organized
um something that we found that is new
in this system was that principational
diabetes leads to significantly
increased uh in the plasmic reticulum
stress and this endoplasmic reticulum
stress in turn leads to abnormal very
long change fatty acid synthesis
metabolics in general so in the upper
panel you can see that the normal
organoids they have
very little oxidative stress but the
registration of diabetes organoids they
have higher oxidative stress but also
the subsidiotic stress it's localized to
the endoplasmic reticulum when we um and
we have more data about this and trying
to summarize it and what we see is that
this stress in the reticulum leads to uh
the decrease in the synthesis of
launching fatty acid precursors that are
used for the synthesis of very launching
fatty acids in the peroxisome and we
think this might connect again with
lipid metabolism and you know aspects of
metabolic syndrome
in in the heart
now that is all work that it's in
progress and we are gearing up to polish
that soon but I'm I I want you to
introduce you to another aspect of this
talk where we have continued developing
the protocol that I initially uh
mentioned
um and so
after modeling the first heart field and
the second heart field and the pro
epicardial organ what we are doing now
is we are trying to reproduce more of
the uh
metabolism and Maternal Fetal
environment conditions and I like to
summarize this I call it developmental
induction and that's what I want to
refer to as an alarm talented action and
it's a combination of factors is
metabolic factors such as glycolysis
versus oxidative phosphorylation so we
provide a more relevant media conditions
to the organoids but it's also related
to the gradual growth the use of
hormones adapting during development
that are sometimes produced by other
organs they were in the heart or by the
mother
and so we develop we decided four uh
different medium conditions a control
condition which is the condition that we
have been using start then we develop a
maturation media condition uh mm which
is a traditional biochemical maturation
method that has been uh you know has
been reported before and then we
developed two additional conditions what
we call enhanced motivation media and
enhanced partition media to one which is
a combination of two maturation media in
an effort to basically recapitulate more
complexity in in those developmental
induction conditions and see how those
affect the development of the organoid
and this is work that is being performed
by Brad balner the very bright vme
graduate student in my lab
and so one of the most surprising things
that we found with this developmental
induction conditions is that they induce
or facilitate a patterning of a hearted
like structure in the organ right so
this organisms stop being such a
spherical organs as you saw before and
then they start elongating and
developing a much more complex structure
um and you can see there a structure of
what the heart tube primitive heart tube
looks like and I want to bring your
attention to that retinoic acid gradient
there which starts on the posterior Pole
where the atrium is forming and the
preparial organ is migrating uh and
where these high concentration of
retinoic acid and that gradient
basically patterns the the Heart Alone
the anterior posterior axis and so what
we saw in our organized with this
developmental induction conditions
particularly in our best condition which
is that emm21 that you can see at the
bottom there is that this induces the
spontaneous organization of a center
that releases retinic acid and that's
this in turns enables you know pattern
with a lot of that axis and we did this
using Roman microscopy using uh with
with one of our collaborators thank you
at MSU that is developing a very
sophisticated Raman microscopy scanning
microscope that can basically
reconstruct the organizing 3D
and so uh here you have a picture of
what these organelles look like uh they
certainly look very far away from those
spherical organisms that we described in
the start
um these Organics have two well distinct
Chambers one of them is ventricular like
another one is atrial-like and then they
have a very nice developed pro-epicial
organ on top of that atrial chamber
which is you know it's very interesting
because it's very capitulated until your
posterior developmental axis and then
there is a a an intramentricular Canal
that connects these two Chambers and
that develops some kind of structures
that are reminding me reminding us of
the endocardial cushions but we still
don't have a lot of information about
what they are
um but um yeah so here you have some
more examples of how these developmental
inductions leads to the reorganization
of the atrial chamber and the Practical
organs so basically here I would call
your attention to the emm21 condition at
the which is the the one that it's uh at
the at the right
where you can see those organoids with
that
shape of remanding a little bit of the
of the embryonic heart and you can see
there the surface of the organized with
that very strong prepicarial organ on
top of the atrial chamber and then you
can see the inside of those organs with
very large dilated Chambers right much
bigger Chambers than what we saw before
in the more primitive organization
um
so these organoids
um develop very nice again I'm calling
your attention to the emm21 slide this
organized the developed very nice atrial
and ventricular identities and you can
see they're unstaining for atrial and
the tubular specific
cardiomyocytes and you can see how they
they basically situate on two opposite
poles of the organoid against supporting
that idea that there is an anterior
posterior axis
and in the borrowed layout you can see
the formation of uh
the expression of aldh-182 which is the
enzyme that synthesizes retinoic acid on
the pole opposite to that ventricular
chamber
although you cannot see that here
because of limitations with the stains
but uh excuse me
um and we can also see that there is
expression of such lines so this is work
in progress we are doing a lot of
progress on this area so I'm giving you
here a little bit of a glimpse into what
we are doing next but we also see this
sucks nine positive cells that make the
valves and the Satan this has been worth
describing guys and the other forming
these anterior posterior pole and they I
would like to call your attention to
that node of socks line positive cells
at the tip of the organoid that the
bottom tip of the organoid which we
believe might be start in septation and
trying to make a separation between that
the tribular chamber into two different
chambers again work in progress we don't
really know if that's that's what's
going to happen but that seems to be
what's going on
um
now just for you to see that about
everything it's it's perfect we have
also seen that the emm21 conditions that
lead to these more advanced organoids uh
hamper the vascularization of the
organoids and so the vascularization
regresses and you can see here these two
animations you can see how the control
arms have very nice muscularization but
the maturated developmentally use organs
have lost a lot of that muscular
motivation uh vascular integration
we are ex we are exciting this a little
bit more in detail
we believe
um
um you know we might be able to till the
timing maybe we are inducing motivation
too fast and this is producing like a
regression of the vascular Network so
this again is work in progress
um hopefully we will find out in the
next
couple of years yeah a couple of months
um
we have very nice uh enhanced
biochemical maturity in the organoids
after developmental induction and so
here you can see in the em21 condition
how the number of mitochondria and the
shape of the mitochondria it's improved
we also see a very nice increase in the
genes on involving oxidative
phosphorylation so you can see those on
the right and you can see in the E and
M21 condition has very strong induction
compared to the other conditions
and we have also enhanced motivation at
the electrophysiological level after
developmental induction so we have
ventricular atrial and another life
cells in the emm21 condition that we do
not see in the other maturation
conditions and now here I have some
pictures uh showing cultural waves in
the ornament so this is our control it
fits nicely but it has some after waves
um
we have our maturation media condition
that has also some
has nice contractions but you can see
some waves that are a little bit out of
synchronization then our emm1 condition
this organ is beat extremely fast we
don't know why they are a little bit
exchange and you can see that also in
the castle waves on the on the right on
the left
um
but here you can see our emm21 organoids
which is they have very synchronized
very strong building um
with uh you know again it's indicative
of motivation
[Music]
um
so before I finish the with with this
talk I'm approaching the end of my
presentation I want to I want to address
the elephant in the room uh which is a
vascularization you know blood flow
um and and yes uh this is something that
it's very important
uh excuse goal for the heart to moderate
and develop correctly and we are missing
this step um
and this is very challenging because
um you know there's a compromise between
having high throughput scalability Etc
and having these organelles connected to
a system that can perfuse them and
provide a correct blood flow
um but we are trying to address this
problem and we are you can see there
several collaborators and people in my
lab that are working on this topic and
hopefully we will have some you know
interesting results in the next couple
of years I would also like to mention
that we have successfully also I'm not
talking about this here today because I
don't have space we have successfully
um integrated neural crest and tissue
residue macrophages in the organoids uh
so uh you know and all of these steps
are basically modular so they are Plug
and Play kind of let me know so we can
control the complexity of the organs and
we can increase it basically at wheel I
could say
anyway with that I hope that I have
convinced you that we can reverse
engineer the human heart to a certain
extent and we can create relevant
initial models for the study of the
human heart for disease modeling
and I would like to acknowledge all the
members of the agira lab our
collaborators at MSU Washington
University Spectrum Health and other
places
and uh yeah and that's that's it for me
if I if there are any questions I'd be
happy to answer them
thank you Dr Aguirre for your
informative presentation we will now
start the live q a portion of the
webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen will answer as
many of your questions as we have time
for
let's get started our first question is
I recently read that there are numerous
factors that could cause the experiment
to include unwanted noise which could
change the accuracy of the findings what
should be taken into account in your
opinion in order to lessen the amount of
noise and inaccurate data used in this
procedure
um that's that's a good question so I I
think what you are basically getting to
is the problem of reproducibility with
art so yes organic other certain
um I'm gonna say bad reputation but they
have a certain reputation for for having
issues with reproducibility sometimes
and I think it boils down to the fact
that as you increase complexity while
things get more complicated right
um
I think the ways to deal with with
reproducibility are basically hard
working into making the sure the
protocols are as simple and
straightforward as possible and making
sure that the quality of the reagents
and everything that you use is is the
best when it's possible and making sure
that people are well trained but I think
an important aspect of this is
conceptual it's making sure that the
methodologies that I use are
reproducible so I I know that many
organoids are made
um by Method methodologies that are kind
of artistic right like people will
take me cell type we saw a cell type and
they will put them together and you know
there's a lot of human factor in there
and that human factor adds to that
reproducibility issue
um so I think we have to try to get rid
of the human factor as much as possible
we have to try to make this a simple and
as automated as possible and that is one
of the efforts that we were trying to
make here that eventually I would like
to have a robot that can actually do
this for me rather than having a person
that has to do it so I think those are
things that we contribute to improving
that their reproducibility
I hope that answers your question
okay perfect our next question here is
as you touched on at the end for drug
Discovery applications you need to
utilize High throughput analysis
techniques with the complexity of the
organoid models are they compatible with
these approaches or do novel approaches
need to be developed such as the custom
flexible micro electrode areas your
colleague developed
yeah that's a great question Valerie um
there's there's truth to both sides of
of the equation basically
um some methods some methodologies that
currently exist can be used
um in unleashing the organisms that we
have but in many cases we are working at
I would say almost the limit of what
those Technologies can offer so for
example we have high content image in
microscopes called focal microscopes
that can
analyze the organism can see through the
organoids and take like stacks of
features Etc but the organizat are in
size at which those microscope size type
to have trouble right so this is
compatible with high content approaches
but it's assigned to push the boundary
of what those High Quantum approaches
can do
um
one of the I think one of the things
that this is going to push forward in
the field is the development of new
technologies basically and we are
working on that you could see that on
the optical Aquarius tomography
microscope that we are designing and we
need technologies that allow that that
allow us to look at these Organics in
more detail
um
more straightforward manners uh
longitudinal analysis non-invasive so
that we don't have to basically destroy
them to to analyze what's going on in
them and I think these Technologies are
going to be key to the advancement of
this organic Technologies they have to
go hand in hand we need the technology
with the organoids and we need the the
Organics themselves yeah
okay thank you our next question here
can you touch upon the benefits of using
self-organized structures that you
mature within the protocol versus 3D
printing of tissue models using mature
cells
yeah I I think that's a actually a great
question I I hear a lot of 3D printing
3D bioprinting
um I think it's really bioprinting it's
great and it's a fantastic approach and
technologically it's a it's a wonder the
product with 3D printing I think at this
point in time maybe in the future is
resolved it's resolution so you can you
can macroscopically print something that
looks like a heart right with a 3D bike
rider you can put cardiomycytes inside
and it would look like a hardware if my
microscopic but if you look at the
microscope at the microscopic level at
that 3D printed heart you will see that
the structure is not the structure of a
of a human heart the cells are not
sufficiently densely packed inside of
that structure and sometimes we don't
even touch each other they don't even
connect and so the cellularity is much
lower the structure is not really
relevant
so I think 3D diet breathing is
currently limited technologically
although it is Advanced very fast so
maybe in a couple of years you know this
this will be this will be feasible but I
think right now
um the emphasis that we are trying to
make is that you know
um basically saying that says if it's if
it's not broken don't fix it right um I
think
um our organs and tissues and cells and
stem cells they know how to make these
organs so why
you know complicated to make uh you know
a very sophisticated methodology to try
to reconstruct it without tissues when
you can actually tell these cells what
to do what to make and they can make it
for you so in terms of cost in terms of
personal in personally involvement Etc
it's easier to create these tissues with
uh you know study with these approaches
that are from simple to more complex
rather than going from
from a you know top-down approach
um but again I think most approaches
have their values and their strong
strength strengths and weaknesses right
so
um yeah that that's what I think
I hope that answers your question
okay great our next question here asking
for more comments about the endothelial
cells as for the vasculature that is
observed in the organoids does it Bear
markers of cardiac tissue and are these
markers different than the vasculature
and other tissues in pathological models
does the vasculature also seem to have
anomalies known of the vasculature
present in the human diseased organ
okay so that's two questions
um so the first question do we do see
some markers that are specific to
arterial and many many cells uh in in
humans the problem is that it's kind of
hard to tell we haven't
uh being able to find like nice coronary
vasculature markers uh if they exist I
would like to know so if someone knows
please let me know
um we see these blood vessels for me so
we don't know if they are more like
microvascular or more like large vessels
but we do see some some gene expression
markers of arterial versus Venus we do
not know if this is coronary vasculature
again I would like to be able to to know
that so if you know any specific markers
for that I would be very happy to check
them out uh regarding the second
question
uh we don't have pathological models of
password so right now we haven't been
doing that
so I I really don't know I cannot answer
specifically we would see Bachelor
abnormalities I imagine we would but we
we haven't done it so it's something I
can we can talk about
okay thank you our next question here if
modeling genetic disease do you start
from genetically altered IPS cells or
from patients derived IPS cells and how
difficult is it to obtain cells from
patients
so um yeah so we can do both we can
start from uh normal ipsc something we
can induce mutations that are you know
Federal copying patient mutations or we
can get a ipcs from patients we have
both and we use both
um
um
how easy or difficult these two things
from patients that well that that is the
main issue right like you know through
things from patients you need an IRB and
uh and you need to find patients with
your disease which in terms of genetic
mutations might be rare diseases so
there might not be a lot of patients
around so sometimes it's just easier to
take the ipcs I'm using crispr just edit
the affected Gene and try to induce the
same mutation in a healthy life
this has the other advantage that you
also have a healthy control line that
it's that is isagenic which sometimes
with patients is difficult to find a
a good control line usually comes from a
relative like a brother or something
like that or clients so yeah
okay thank you and it looks like we have
time for one more question today do you
know uh if the model of heart organoids
is being used to test Gene editing
Therapeutics which you expect to
encounter issues with penetrants in
vitro
um
I don't know straight right of the body
if it's being used to test genetic
Therapeutics but it probably is I mean I
since we published this I I like more
than 80 100 Labs have contacted me too
implement this methodologies so I would
guess that some of them might be using
emaility in Therapeutics so I wouldn't
be surprised uh in terms of the
advantages and limitations of using this
model for that I think it has a lot of
advantages
um and this goes in line with that last
question if you would respect your
counter issues with penetrants in vitro
I think the beauty of the organized is
that it gives you more complexity than a
single cell layer in vitro but it's
still not as complicated as dealing with
the whole animal
so sometimes in animals you have
penetrance issues right because there is
a lot of things going on and you knock
out the gene but you know there's some
compensation there's robustness in the
tissues organs Etc in the organic we
don't have this we don't have this level
of robustness and issues of compensation
can be more you know can be controlled
better so
if if any we have the opposite problem
we have very good penetrance usually
that's what I would say so like a
phenotype that in Mouse it's maybe more
in the gray area in the organs usually
it's it's very clear-cut because
um it's a little bit exaggerated you
could say because there's not the other
pieces and organs around that help you
know maintain the facility of that
organism it's not a close secret
basically it's just an isolated part of
it so they are going to usually responds
very well and we have done some
experiments with this and um it lies
with genetic with some genetic mutations
and we see very spectacular results from
from from the Organics in terms of
structure the effects on the structure
and the cell types Etc are very
interesting
okay thank you so much Dr Gary do you
have any final comments for our audience
um no I just wanted to say thank you
very much for attending and I hope you
enjoyed the talk on the the information
presented
thank you again Dr Aguirre for your time
today and your important research we
would also like to thank lab roots and
our sponsors BPS bioscience for
underwriting today's educational webcast
before we go I'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions questions we
did not have time for today and those
submitted during the on-demand period
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information you provided at the
time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
Roots will alert you via email when it's
available for replay we encourage you to
share that email with your colleagues
who may have missed today's live event
until next time goodbye